Stephen Colbert, I just love him.
And he shared his pre-show ritual.
He does something interesting before every show.
He told The Wall Street Journal that every night
before he goes out, he slaps himself in the face.
(Drew laughs)
Not once, but twice.
What?
Yes, and he said, hard enough to wish he hadn't done it.
And it's his way of bringing himself present,
like into the moment.
He says, "I'll never get another chance to do those jokes
or interview that person or be present for that audience."
So he wants to wake himself up just so he can be there.
I love Stephen Colbert so much-
Oh yeah.
That it hurts my soul.
This is interesting.
The slapping is a unique approach, especially twice.
But I really take some life lessons from the,
you will never do this interview again,
you will never be with this group of guests,
which is called an audience, but I think of it as guests.
And I think that, all slapping aside,
I love the, we won't get this moment back,
so going into it knowing that might shift the perspective.
I like it.
I like it too.
Yeah.
Different way of thinking.
(audience applauds)
I love that.
Well, next, there is scientific proof
that nostalgia makes us feel better.
Martha Stewart reports that the Chinese Academy of Sciences
has found that looking at nostalgic images reduces pain.
Isn't this fascinating?
They hooked subjects up to an fMRI machine
and put a heat generator on their arm,
and then they showed them modern or nostalgic images.
The group looking at nostalgic cartoons
or games from childhood
felt less pain from the burny thing.
(audience laughs)
And had reduced activities in parts of the brain
associated with pain perception.
So, I mean, gosh, if you got some cramps,
break out the Bugs Bunny.
Ross, what do you think about this?
I mean, okay, good, I think good.
But not for me.
No, if I have a headache,
I'm not gonna turn on "Jem and the Holograms",
give me an Advil, you know what I mean?
(audience laughs)
I mean, "Sex and the City" cuts pain for me all the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, I'll do that.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I didn't know we could do that, yes, okay.
A big creamy bowl of macaroni and cheese deluxe
and some "Sex and the City" is totally my go-to for pain.
Yeah, take me to the Aidan years
and that will cure anything, right?
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
(Drew laughs)
Well, listen, if you love love, like we love love,
we've got a modern love story that shows
you can find love just about anywhere if you look.
This story's going viral right now.
Jonah Taylor recently received a scratched record
from an online store.
He bought a record.
Well, when he logged in to call customer service,
he seemed to really hit it off
with the customer service rep named Pablo,
and after his issue was resolved,
very smoothly by Pablo by the way,
Jonah took a real leap.
Drew, you're gonna love this.
He asked, "Are you single?"
And it turns out Pablo was single and the rest is history.
They've already gone on their first Zoom date,
and they say they are taking things slow,
but they found love over the customer service line.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
You guys.
I love this.
Press one to speak to an agent,
press 0 to oh.
(Drew laughs)
I love it, Drew.
Well, I say we go out there and we be bold and respectful,
but you know...
ask, why not?
(upbeat bright music)